I'm sitting here with Mike,
one of the web developers at Udacity.
I heard you wrote some
pretty bad code recently.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] That was quite the experience.
>> Yeah, I actually remember, because
I gave you that bad code assignment.
>> [LAUGH] You did.
>> So, so basically in a nutshell,
what did I tell you to do?
>> You, you came up with an app idea,
and you just told me, all right,
now forget all the things you know
to do right, and, and do it wrong.
And try to make it a rough experience.
>> So build a spaghetti code app.
>> Build a spaghetti code application.
>> And how did you feel?
I was really excited because I knew
I didn't have to maintain this thing.
I was just going to crank
out an application for
you really quick, get it done in hour or
two and and just get code on
the screen and feel super productive.
So I was, I was kind of excited to not
have to put whole lot of brain power to
it and just do it.
Yeah it's kind of old
habits in a way right.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Because everyone kind of learns
spaghetti code and then learns how
to organize their code later on.
>> It reminded me of like ten years ago.
Like the type of work I was doing.
[LAUGH].
>> So you had this app.
You didn't have to maintain it.
You felt great about it.
>> Mm-hm.
>> How do you feel by the end?
>> Pretty bad.
[LAUGH].
>> Really, why?
>> Well it was a miserable
experience when it got to the end.
There was a point that I actually
coded myself into a corner.
>> Oh.
>> And
I had a problem that I knew, like I knew
myself was a simple problem to solve.
But, because of the way I
had built the application
it was no longer a simple problem to
solve, it was actually really difficult.
And then I just felt bad because I,
I knew where this code was going.
>> I see.
Well, actually,
Nick Artman one of our other front end
engineers-
>> Mm-hm.
>> Likens it to diving for
the finish line.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you dive for
the finish line too early,
well, you get scraped up.
Right?
And things seem really bad and
it takes a lot more effort to go
then and finish the, the race.
>> That's-.
>> That's a very good metaphor about it.
>> I basically told you to die
right out of the starting block.
>> [LAUGH] Right.
Yeah.
I, I thought I was done with
the application before I had ever
started it really, and so I was just
[NOISE] trying to get stuff done and
if I would have taken my time to like,
really plan it out ahead of time and,
and know what I was going to do
throughout everything it would have
been a much more enjoyable experience.
>> All right.
So if you want to blame someone for
this experience you can blame Mike.
>> You told me to do it.
>> If you want to blame someone for
this experience, you can blame me.
Bad advice.
[LAUGH] Awesome.
Well, thanks Mike for sitting with me.
>> Uh-huh.